let's talk about net neutrality I came
to you on December 19th of 2017 it feels
like so long ago but it was not even a
month ago and I told you the Senate is
going to vote on restoring net
neutrality Chuck Schumer and a couple of
others in the Senate are going to
sponsor it but are they going to be able
to get anybody else to jump on board and
then January 9th I came to you and I
said hey that bill to reverse the net
neutrality repeal now has 30 sponsors
but can they get more can they even get
enough to get 250 votes or 51 votes in
the Senate well the Washington Post as
of this morning is reporting that
according to top Democrats yesterday 55
zero senators have now endorsed a
measure called the congressional review
act to override the recent repeal of
Obama era net neutrality regulation so
what this means is that they need just
one more Republican to come over to
their side to get 51 votes right now
they've got 49 Democrats all 49
Democrats in the Senate plus Susan
Collins from Maine she is one of the
five or so Republicans that on some
issues will sometimes vote with
Democrats great news right why is this
bad well no it's obviously very good you
get one more vote and then it passes the
Senate and then it fails in the house or
if it's somehow passes the house which
it won't it will be vetoed by Donald
Trump who would need to sign it for it
to take effect if Jesus Christ himself
showed up and said hey yes I am the
Jewish carpenter in the sky that you
guys have been talking about for a
couple thousand years I was born to a
virgin and I want net neutrality
Republicans in the house would still
probably say now we misunderstood Jesus
we're not voting they would have to
check with the president first yeah like
who was it that said that Trump
supporter on CNN yeah he's a even if
Jesus told me X and Trump told me why I
would double check with Trump to see
whether it's X or Y so even Susan
Collins's vote for this is a safe one
her district on many issues is sort of
to the left of the more extreme
Republican Party she can sign on to this
knowing number one it's never going to
pass and number two it will probably be
good for her politically but what is the
mechanism that is at play here why is it
that Democrats are doing this
if ultimately it's up to Trump whether
it gets signed into law or not well the
way it works is that any agency that's
independent FCC is one of those they
make a decision and elected officials
get 60 days 60 legislative days I
believe it is where they can reverse the
decision under the Congressional review
act that's what they're trying to do but
if it's not going to pass what is the
point of this I've been talking to you
about it now for three weeks nearly a
month but if it's not going to pass
what's the point the point is make this
a campaign issue for 2018 and maybe even
2020 over whelmingly the American public
supports net neutrality provisions force
Republicans to defend when they're up
for re-election in 2018 or 2020 force
them to defend not voting in support of
those popular net neutrality provisions
make it possible for Democrats to run
against Republicans on this and to also
run on having supported I guess we would
call it repealing the repeal of net
neutrality there is one real way if you
want solutions and you want them now to
force Trump's hand on this and you know
what it is Pat I've been saying it for a
while we've got to take control of the
House and Senate in 2018 and then that's
how we might actually be able to force
Trump's hand Trump's hands on this but
this is actually one of the top issues
that shows that our system just isn't
working American voters say net
neutrality is not controversial we
wanted even Republicans generally
Republican voters generally want net
neutrality unless they've been
brainwashed by the corporate talking
points the country wants net neutrality
our elected officials seem split almost
exactly 50/50 on this wait a second I
thought they represented us Pat I
thought they represented the
constituents how can you have such
agreement on an issue among voters which
is really rare in American politics and
then among our elected officials it's a
50/50 partisan split well I do think it
will pass the Senate but just barely and
I think the good that comes out of that
is then you have a conversation about if
it could pass the House and if it could
be passed by the president and then
maybe we'll have a reporter asked Trump
what his opinion on that neutrality is
and I'd like to hear that get him on
record saying that he's opposed to it
yeah or taking the FCC's side in some
way
Eliott supporters what has he he's
basically said that he's against it but
he doesn't really know what it is he
said that it's the fairness darkness or
not he's against it like a total
misunderstanding of what it is okay so
it I actually do think generally I'm
against would we call this a political
stunt I mean it's kind of a stunt in a
sense but it actually might lead to
passage in the Senate
generally I'm against wasting taxpayer
money for these doomed to fail ideas but
there might actually be a greater good
here which is that it could be used in
2018 success I think that if it can pass
one side of Congress it's not doomed to
fail you know then it's well worth it
they're halfway there fair enough you
are in a sense even if you're gonna be
way upside down in the house send me
your thoughts on this is this just a
waste of taxpayer money or is this
actually something useful possibly to
quote vote them out in 2018 I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show today's
program is sponsored in part by wink
spelled wi and see i like to try to
appear knowledgeable about wine I like
showing up to social events with a
bottle and being able to say something
about why I like it
but I'm really just not very good at
that and that's what wink makes very
easy for anybody to do to discover great
wines because what they do is every
month they ship you wines that are
matched to your tastes and personalized
to you you take a six question sort of
like a wine palate quiz and based on
answering questions like how you like
your coffee if at all or whether you
like blueberries or raspberries the
system will figure out what wines you
are likely to enjoy and then over time
as you rate wines in the wink system the
recommendations become even more
personalized to your taste tastes so to
try it you can go to try wink comm slash
Pakman that's try WI and see.com slash
Pakman do the palate profile quiz after
answering those questions you'll start
getting great wines personalized and
delivered right to your door no
membership fees you can skip any month
cancel anytime and wink has a 100%
satisfaction guarantee so you never end
up paying for a bottle that you don't
like and for a limited time you can get
$20 off when you go to try wink comm
slash Pakman that's t ry winc dot-com
slash Pakman for $20 off